so with age of Ultron issue number 10 we
get the conclusion to this event but
what we also get is the results of what
happened with Wolverine tampering with
time of what happened when Wolverine had
effectively broken time and as we start
this story we see that a package is
delivered to hate him around the time
that Holtz wrong Ultron attempts to take
over the world about some months before
the forces of the Avengers successfully
or I guess I encounter Ultron when he's
really conform oast part he doesn't know
who deliver this package although is
revealed to us to be Susan storm but
when he opens it up it's simply
something or a device of some kind of
plays videos that simply says play me on
it and when he plays it it's a video of
himself from the past and what he tells
his future self is that there's a reason
why he doesn't remember making this
video that he had been made to forget
now we know that the reason why he had
forgotten is making this video or the
events around it was because Ultron had
modified his memories when Hank Pym
first first created Ultron and of course
this was something that was explained to
us way back in the Avengers comics when
the vision had first appeared Marvel had
simply just used this as an explanation
to why it is that Hank Pym doesn't
remember making this video but what is a
past self says is that of all the things
that they had screwed up of all the
things all the mistakes they had ever
made that creating Ultron was the worst
one that because of this Ultron is going
to enact a set of actions a set of
circumstances that is going to lead to
almost the end of the world as far as
they know and so what he says is that
Hank Pym is going to have to do
something that he's getting ready to
tell him that he's going to have to
start a project that is going to
effectively allow him to defeat Ultron
at this point we jump back to the point
in which Ultron first reawakens when he
first arrives and of course the Avengers
are doing what they can to combat Ultron
to try to bring an end to Ultron but
again because of the power that Ultron
possesses because of the sheer strength
that he has and his adamantium physique
Rosetta mantium body he's able to easily
take on the Avengers unable to easily
overpower almost all of them but in
addition to this Ultron realizes that
something's going on here that
something's taking place now initially
the idea is that
thinks that perhaps it maybe something
tied into Tony Stark but he also
believes that Hank Pam has something to
do with this and as they're fighting the
questions being asked is Hank Pam doing
it is Hank to him working on whatever it
is he's working on and hank pym says yes
hank pym says that he's still loading
something now we're presuming that this
is the virus that hank pym had created
although we don't know if that's an
absolute fact
but again hank pym says that ultron is
for the most part fighting this that
he's going to figure out what's going on
and when he does he's going to shut it
down and so he says the Avengers have to
do something they had to find some way
to stall him and so as the Avengers are
fighting fighting Ultron Ultron is
learning what's taking place of course
we see that Abigail brand with sword is
calling in reinforcements but for the
most part again Ultron is figuring out
what's taking place he realizes that a
Hank Pym is involved in this somehow
that Hank Pym is doing something to
alter his coding to alter his
programming and Ultron deduces that what
Hank Pym is trying to do is to shut him
down to deprogram him by reprogramming
and this is what Ultron says Ultron says
that for the most part this isn't going
to work that he is effectively closing
every backdoor that Hank Pym opens that
he is correcting Hank Pym x' code as
it's being uploaded to ultron and so
again Ultron gets mad about this Ultron
feels insulted by the fact that Hank Pym
would try something as basic as more or
less creating a Trojan backdoor in
Ultron's programming and so what
Ultron's says here is that for the most
part he believes that it's time for
humanity's existence to come to an end
that humanity doesn't serve a purpose
that the Avengers serve no purpose and
that he's going to effectively shut
everybody down he's going to kill them
all and he is presumably going to take
over the world but at this point what we
see is that whatever it is that Hank Pym
had done appears to have been successful
when Ultron begins to spaz a little bit
and then all of a sudden completely
shuts down and so what we get is this
explanation from Hank em Hank Pym says
that what he had done what he created an
Ultron was more or less of a ruse it was
trick he had effectively tried to create
a back door in Ultron's programming and
Ultron sensing this back door attempted
to shut it down but when he did it
activated a subroutine that had already
been created by Hank Pym when he first
created Ultron and when the subroutine
was activated it created a
self-replicating virus that shut Ultron
down but by the time that Ultron had
realized what this virus was it was too
late and he was seconds away from from
shutting down entirely and so for the
most part again the question is asked
here by by Iron Man by Tony Stark is how
was it that Hank Pym knew this how he
knew that something like that needed to
be done how he knew that something like
that needed to be done at this
particular moment in time but Hank Pym
for the most part doesn't answer him
from here we switch back to a Susan
storm as she is travelling with
Wolverine back to the Baxter building
and Wolverine tells her to enjoy her
life to enjoy spending time with her
family to make sure her family loves her
and as of course the two begin to part
ways there's some kind of a massive
shake within the city of New York and of
course we see multiple variations of
Wolverine in fact almost every major
alternate reality of Wolverine up
hearing of course we see old man Logan
among others we also see the same thing
with Ironman and for the most part we
don't really know what's taking place
here we don't know what's going on here
all we really know is that perhaps
something's going on that's caused a
backlash maybe a kind of blowback as a
result of Wolverine manipulating reality
at this point we jump to two beasts -
Hank McCoy along with Tony Stark and I
believe Reed Richards I'm sorry I'm Hank
Pym and the question that's being asked
here is what's happened what's going on
and so what what Tony Stark more or less
guesses is that time has been broken
that the space-time Continuum's been
broken by Wolverine and for the most
part Hank Pym akattak appetizers on this
Hank Pym says that his guess is that
because wolverine had a had continually
jumped back and forward in time because
he had repeatedly abused time that he
had more or less
I guess torn the space-time continuum
and that again no one really knows
what's going to take place no one knows
what kind of other realities may be
affected and at this point we switched
to the ultimate universe with Miles
Morales as spider-man and as he was
figuring out his powers as he's learning
and beginning to become undertake the
role of spider-man again there's some
kind of massive flash in the sky and
when he looks up he sees the silhouette
of Galactus but what we also see and
quite possibly more important than this
is the arrival of Angela into the Marvel
Universe with that being said we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if
you did let me know and let me know what
you guys thought about this age of
Ultron series if it was something that
you guys really really enjoyed and if
you did we'll definitely try to do more
like it where that being said I will
catch you guys later peace
you